last question today hey David how will
Joe Biden handle Ukraine attacks from
Donald Trump if he becomes the nominee
this this is a good question because
this has already come up and Joe Biden
is completely mangled the answer I
believe that Joe Biden needs to fight
back when that issue comes up if Joe
Biden is the nominee and issues of
Hunter Biden's job at the Ukrainian gas
company are woven into the discussion
about Trump and impeachment the other
day I saw an interview that Joe Biden
gave where he was asked about it and he
just said he seemed totally disoriented
he seemed dazed almost how has he not
come up with a strong answer on this
issue he's already looking weak about it
so a few thoughts that I have number one
Biden needs a strategy I would sort of
workshop it and there's a few different
angles you could take one angle you
could take a say oh hold on a second
hold on a second
the Trump administration has Trump's
unelected children doing high-level work
you've got Rudy Giuliani's son working
in the White House you have William Bars
son working in the White House or
somewhere associated with the
administration
you've got the president's kids
regularly meeting with foreign leaders
maybe the fact that hunter Biden got a
job at a gas company is not actually the
biggest concern right now when you've
got Ivanka sitting in for the Secretary
of State or whatever it was that she was
doing a couple years ago at the g20
that's one angle the counter to that is
you're sort of muddying it up because
you're not really defending anything
you're just saying Trump is doing it
worse so another angle that you could
take is something like listen I've
helped my children to be successful
you've helped yours neither has anything
to do with you being impeached for your
bribery and extortion of Ukraine you are
an impeached president you're desperate
to distract etc etc that might be sort
of like a stronger way to go about it
I'm not a political messaging expert but
what I can tell you is but when Joe
Biden was asked about this the other day
how do you not have a planned answer for
it you were going to get a hundred
versions of basically the same question
isn't there something to why hunter
Biden had this cushy job on the get on
the board of this Ukrainian gas company
isn't it true that for whatever Trump
did wrong there maybe there should be an
investigation into what went on with you
and Hunter but he's gonna be asked this
a hundred different ways he's got to be
strong on it he's completely bungled it
so far in a cringe-worthy embarrassing
way and he if he is going to be the
nominee and he's not the nominee yet and
maybe he won't be but if he is if he
can't be prepared for that in a strong
way which it'll require a level of
strength we've not really seen from Joe
Biden this campaign other than in very
isolated instances he's gonna get
crushed by Trump you will have an
impeached president making Joe Biden
look bad on issues surrounding what led
to the impeachment unless Joe Biden can
be properly prepared I want to hear from
you how do you believe that Joe Biden
should answer those questions leave a
reply as a comment if you're watching on
YouTube otherwise send me a tweet at D
Pakman